- You remember Kim from Mark V
fiberglass?
You got your seat.
- Yeah, yeah.
When I was over there
picking up buggy parts,
she was talking to me
about her bug she's got
and a Mach 1 that she
and her husband had.
Look at this bad boy.
This has got to be the spot.
I had to get my
mind off of pinstripes
and graphics for a minute.
Kim Ball-- she's a legend
in the car business.
She knows everything about cars.
In fact, she was the first
woman to work behind a parts
counter in the entire country.
She lives here in Vegas
and invited me to stop by.
I just hope Mike can keep
his mouth shut long enough
to maybe learn a thing or two.
Look at that.
It's a '66?
I don't know.
'66, I think.
You know I'm ignorant when
it comes to these things.
Yeah, it's '66.
Wow, that's a beautiful Mustang.
All right, before we go
gawking all over her ride,
let's go get her first.
No soliciting.
Maybe you should have
waited in the car.
I don't know.
I gotta look it up, see
what it really means.
Maybe they got a dog
for you to play with.
That'll be good.
You like dogs.
- I like cats better.
- How are you doing?
KIM: Hi, how are you?
- Kim--
Hi, Kim.
We're here to check out your
Mach 1 you were talking about.
OK, well, if you want
to go around to the front,
I'll open the garage doors.
- Cool.
- All right.
- Very cool.
All right.
Dude, I'm a sucker
for '69 Mach 1s.
I really am.
I love bugs.
That's your daily driver?
KIM: Daily driver.
That one looks cool.
I like all the
upgrades you're doing.
I like the split window.
Typically, they're
not done very well.
And they look bad.
That one looks cool.
Well, you know,
that one opens, too.
So you got a bug hatchback.
The struts allow me to
open it three different ways.
This is completely open.
RYAN: OK.
And then you can bring
it down to where it's
only open like this far up.
And, if you pop the back windows
at the same time, you really--
RYAN: It's like a
wind tunnel in there.
You can really
get a lot of wind.
RYAN: Nice.
You gotta have cup holders.
RYAN: I like the tray.
KIM: So I made a tray.
Wow, '69 Mach 1-- as
far as I'm concerned,
the only Mustangs
on this planet--
and I know a lot of people
are going to hate me for it--
is the '69.
That's it.
1969 was the first
year Ford introduced
the Mach 1, replacing the GT as
its premiere performance model.
The Mustang's body style
changed drastically
this year to make it more
competitive during the muscle
car craze.
With new quad
headlights up front
and a wider, longer,
more muscular body,
this pony car was
built to give Camaros,
Firebirds, and [inaudible]
a run for their money.
The Mach 1 model was insanely
powerful and popular,
accounting for almost
a quarter of all
the Mustangs sold that year.
This is the original
paint on the car.
This is the original interior.
And the drive train had
been stripped out of it.
We found the guy that originally
bought the car in Pennsylvania.
So we went up, and we got
the drive train from the--
He still had--
He still had it
wrapped in plastic.
And that's what's
made this what it is.
RYAN: This is an--
You still got your
numbers matching.
This is a numbers--
This is an all original,
numbers matching--
MIKE: That's awesome.
So I guess you want to
see if she's real or not.
Well I just-- well,
you know-- hey--
Hey, a motor's a motor.
You want to see a 428.
Not that I really, truly
know the difference--
Oh, man.
That is-- that's
a factory AC part?
Factory AC.
Damn, this thing is
stuffed in there, too.
I can't believe that
this is all original--
like the graphics, everything.
Everything on this car is real.
KIM: Everything is original.
Damn near down to the tires--
I mean, how can you own
a '69 with a 428 Cobra Jet
and not have Polyglas tires?
You have to.
They literally don't look right.
This is way better
than any 401K.
I mean, this is
really a retirement
plan sitting in your garage.
KIM: And it didn't
start out at that.
It just started out as a
car that I loved driving.
And I have driven it
all over the country.
I'll be damned.
Well that was well
worth my lunch hour.
Kim did a beautiful job on
the mods on her Volkswagen.
And seriously, '69 Mustang--
that thing was gorgeous.
You only see a car like
that once, maybe twice,
in a lifetime-- beautiful car.